and done things that's just how good men
are i'm sorry no i'm not even i'm not
talking about the the athletics i'm
talking about the women that you are
completely disagreeing with everybody
but i actually don't disagree like i
agree with all of you but just a
different perspective
someone who's grown up in the music
business especially jazz
jazz has taught me a lot of things about
the world and culture that the rest of
the world didn't teach me
um jazz taught me that i could be black
but can i ask you a question what does
it mean to be black what okay to have
seoul are you black no
but but it's so
inspiring it showed you how to be black
in america maybe but what about black
people in africa or nigeria or
could you explain that i need you to
explain that more
well um
there may be some people who disagree
with me but i believe that in a large
part
the american art form
as jazz of jazz
is very much a black art form it's not
only black
there is a whole movement out there
that's pushing black american music and
trying to call jazz black american music
i disagree wholeheartedly because that
uh eliminates the latin american
influence that eliminates all the other
influences that have made jazz what it
is today
but
anybody who plays jazz anybody who loves
jazz can not
self-respectingly say that it's not a
black music
so when i play with black musicians
my biggest compliment
is when
you got the 75 year old bass player
that's in there watching you like who
the hell is this mother
who just walked up to the stage thinking
he knows what he's doing
and he you play a little bit and you
look back did i do okay and he just goes
how does how does that
how does that make you black okay okay
that
that that's one degree of the acceptance
over the years i've had many musicians
tell me oh yeah you're honorary black
you're straight okay okay
now i'm not saying that
but i understand
what black music is and what makes
music that that culture i understand
where gospel comes from i understand
where slavery
led to the roots of what became jazz i
understand
how pain
produces art
doesn't mean that i'm black i'm saying
that black people have over the years in
my in my business have made me feel
accepted into their community and have
many times told me straight up you're
the you're the blackest brown guy i know
so that's one thing that's one thing
i think one problem that's just that's
not me saying i'm black
for me that's one thing that
i i haven't heard any other ethnicity
any other race say
give out
freely give out like oh you're this yeah
you're black you're black you're black
and like give it out to people that's
something that frustrates me
because we there's no white car
we're so accepting as a community and
i would i would if i heard you play and
i'm like oh that that boy got so like
man he can actually play and it's like
accepting by the black community when
you
do things that are essentially from the
black community and they accept you but
we just freely oh like we got a stack of
black cards in our back pocket and we
boo everybody gets one but as soon as
someone in the black community does
something that is not black we snatch it
quick and it's so frustrating and i'm
not saying that that's uh like what you
experience is a bad thing but
i do not think that you can
change your race because it's different
from
i don't i just don't think you can
change it because there's more in it
than just your skin color or just saying
that you're from wherever you are and
just saying i'm this now it is so my
question
right is that
would you
understand that maybe
amongst the peers and the people that
you've like been around they've accepted
you and like they've they've allowed you
into their space that they may even call
sacred at some point would you
understand that
that past isn't
all the way around absolutely okay i
would never say that now i'm black
because somebody black put their hand on
my shoulder
i would say that i've been accepted
by the the people who made this music
for me to come and play
i i've been
invited to the tribe
that doesn't mean that i'm black
and for the same reason so that's why i
bring out this opposing view is to to
prove the point that anybody who claims
to be something they're not simply
because they decide to do so is actually
disrespecting that which they're trying
to claim
because for me to call myself black
would be
absolutely disrespectful
to those people that i look up to and
want their acceptance but the thing that
i find really crazy is the way
everyone's reacted so energetically to
the idea of you being black because you
play the saxophone very well
people don't have that same energy when
it comes to the original question you
know you know a man saying he's a woman
a woman saying they're a man and i think
it's interesting how slowly over time
you know
people push you know the envelope slowly
slowly slowly so when you make
acceptance for someone saying they oh i
feel like i'm black so i am black and
you saying oh it's okay to think that
and then you know as long as you don't
force me to do it but that's how it
initially starts and then it becomes and
grows more into more you know
there's now like an older gentleman
about 50 55 60 years old identifying
it's a 13 year old yep yep
i just think get out of here
i just think that there's a special
place in hell for them
jesus
have you guys ever seen the videos where
they give out n-word passes oh my
goodness
and people like
my guy
are they pay people they're like nah nah
nah i'm not going there oh my goodness i
just think i guess that's a good
question why is it okay for some groups
of people to say racial slurs
about themselves
but not others because latinos have it
too mm-hmm
well with with
in
the us okay you know the way it was
explained to me and because i don't use
i don't use the n-word you know
um
i don't think no i don't use it um but
like the way the way growing up
the way we always talked about it's our
own locker room issue you know what i'm
saying like you're not allowed to
you know if you're not in the locker
room you're not allowed to use the word
in the context which was something i
disagreed with
but that's just based on the fact that
you know my cultural experience growing
up in the us
you know i had people
who weren't who were african-american
calling me an wooden drug and i took it
the wrong way because looking at seeing
it on tv growing up it didn't seem like
an appropriate word to use so it didn't
seem appropriate being said to me
you know but as i grew up in the culture
i understood the context in which it's
used i still don't use it but i
understand how so i understand why
it's a problem if
someone outside speech
sorry to your point before um
about like you playing jazz
you know if if if i'm in the other room
and you're playing
you know and i'm like wow that that's a
good player and i didn't know what you
look like
you know but i'm like but you're a new
guy like you said you're playing with
the 75 year old or something like that
and
if i came in i was like wow you were the
one that was playing you know
that's me
you know accepting you i wouldn't think
that you were black
but i would say oh this this guy can
play culturally that i look at in the
cultural context i like culturally okay
this guy's in like he gets the soul of
how we play and how we however it is
he's been immersed in it long enough you
know